well let me ask the
the biggest question one that you also
touch in your book
but one that i asked every once in a
while is what is the meaning of life
the meaning of my life is many different
things
okay but it but they are all kind of
centered around um relationships
um i mean for a christian one's
relationship with god
is a crucial part of the meaning of life
but one's relationship with one's family
wife's
wife parents children grandchildren in
my case
and so forth those are crucially
important
um these are all the places where people
whether they're religious or not
find meaning
but ultimately i think a person who has
faith in a creator um who
we think has a
an intention or many intentions but a
but
but but i will um
in respect of the world as a whole
that's
a crucial part of meaning and
the idea that my life might have
some small significance
in the plan of that creator
is an amazingly powerful
idea that give that brings meaning
i tell a story in my book that um when i
was a student before i became a
christian i read a philosophy book
whose approximate title was um what you
know what is the meaning of life and
you know that book basically said there
is no meaning to life you have to make
up the meaning as you go along
and i think that's probably the the
predominant
secular view is these days that there is
no real meaning but you can make up a
meaning and
that will give you meaning into your
life i
don't subscribe to that view anymore um
i think there is more meaning than that
but i do think that those things which
give meaning to our life are very
important and we should emphasize them
and you you have said that as the part
of the
as the part of that meaning is the part
of your faith
love and loyalty are key parts
so can you try to say
what is love and loyalty
like what
what does it mean to you
what does it look like
if you were to give advice to uh to your
children grandchildren of what to look
for
in in looking for loyalty and and love
what would you try to say well i think
it's something like
yielding your will or
desire to another um
it's valuing others more highly
or at least as highly as yourself but
that's just the start of it because true
love
re you reach a point where you
are you feel compelled by the other
and that i think to some people sounds
very
scary but actually it's terrifically
liberating
um and i think that
love then brings you into service
towards another and i'm
you know reminded of the
phrase from the anglican uh prayer book
where
it talks about um jesus whose service is
perfect freedom in other words
for us christians to serve god
is what perfects our freedom and i think
there is
an amazing love as um
is in part capped captivity
but in a kind of paradoxical sense it's
also an amazing
freedom love is freedom i don't think
there's a
better way to end it we started with
fusion energy and ending on love
and there's a huge honor to talk to you
thank you so much for your time today
thanks it was a pleasure
you